the Joe Rogan experience listen man
Kevin Lee coming up to you worked out
thank you by the way my pleasure [ __ ] I
knew it he set us up together
I knew it though when he was talking him
I knew he was like a little bit lost and
trying to figure out his way and I said
man you need a head coach and I'm like
who fights like you George George st.
Pierre I mean not saying is the same
levels George but it's George fights
like that with wrestling and great
striking and submissions he mixes it all
up he's unpredictable in his attacks
like the very similar they're neither
one of them are particularly long both
guys are very physically strong I might
come on man I guess this is the guy he
has a great training team already
he doesn't have somebody kind of put it
all together yes and you know we're
talking about styles and never he's a
bit of a like his personality is a walk
yet like he's you know he's a he's a
commando and me I'm the opposite I'm
like calculated I'm a scalpel
yeah he's a changed psalmist together it
makes a great blend yes you need you
need both a little bit of discipline a
little bit of yes yeah there's a time
and place for both yes so like his last
fight of happy state discipline very so
very much so very much so and he could
become world champion if he's
disciplined because George was very
disciplined yes
he didn't veer off the game plan at all
and he got the job Diamond that chaos I
also told him all that [ __ ] that he does
or he's getting moving up to the cage
he's dancing around and going crazy I'm
like a band in that [ __ ] I go come out
like a [ __ ] samurai man some serious
work to do mm-hmm now that stuff is
complicating your mind because then you
have to think all I did if I could lose
right now I'm gonna look stupid well
then Dancing and and there's all this
pretending that you're not feeling the
feeling that you're feeling right now
you're feeling this incredible moment
because you six months of preparation
getting ready for this one moment here
it is embrace what that is go Zen man
being be empty and he was like that the
whole training camp way he was very
focused for this one you could tell yes
you know I was really happy because I
like guys would come in the gym and work
they don't skip practice and like if
guys tell me I'm I'm I'm I'm not in
today for
I'll let them okay you don't to be and
you don't to be in like I'll tell them
look I think you should be in but you
don't want to come in what could I do
right but he was very disciplined he
came to all the practices and it worked
out beautifully like this I hold is he
now
uh maybe late 20s no I'm not even sure I
think he I want to say he's 26 it
tunnels is Kevin moody 27 27 what's his
birthday September ok so he just turned
27 yeah yeah he's [ __ ] not even in
his prime you know and he's also
experienced failure and that experience
fights where he didn't live up to his
potential and I think that ultimately
will be a motivating force because we
see what he can do when he's really
focused that Greger girl SP is a
dangerous bite man you know mean people
see that spectacular head kick knockout
and they don't understand how good
gregor Gillespie is that kid is a savage
and so when I found out that Kevin was
gonna fight Gregor in his fight back to
155 not a good comeback like dangerous
come back fine yeah very high-risk a
very high-risk and also getting down to
155 what did you guys do differently to
get him down to 155 easily this time we
kind of put our heads together you know
do we Cooper his trainer is really great
fantastic amazing I mean I love working
with him brilliant guy his brother Keith
we kind of like got our heads together
and like look we got to keep losing
weight at this rate no matter what it
takes and if you protests like you know
if he wants to like ease up well listen
to about we he's got he's got to bite
the bullet at one point like we can't go
fall behind this rate of losing weight
we have to lose on a pound an hour every
hour we have to lose one pound and like
at a certain point now it's a pound an
hour you talking about for the weight
cut weight cut yeah we can right but
what is he coming in like what it's like
when he the week of the fight on Monday
morning what is he waiting in it got it
on your phone yeah head here so look a
little smaller but healthy yes didn't
look sucked in he didn't look like he
depleted himself did he do anything
different in terms of like weight
lifting or running extra running
I wouldn't lift weights if I was him I I
don't want him to lift any weights
because he's naturally like I like I
like bulking and then cutting mm-hmm
I don't like cutting cutting cutting but
when he came to me it was six weeks
before so we were in a cutting phase
like I don't want him to bulk up because
in six weeks you can't bulk and then cut
he's already very naturally muscular
he's very naturally strong naturally
already so I had him doing roadwork
roadwork not too much plyometric not
like a little bit but I don't want to
put any size on him because he's got
enough size right so first thing is
evaluation does he need muscle no he's
plenty of muscle right does he need
power plenty of power we need to we need
to create endurance and discipline in
him that's why I think was making the
big difference and some technical issues
and we cut the 24 hours before he was
174 M hmm 174 so 20 pounds that's a lot
it's a lot so there was a point where we
had to hit after losing a preliminary
weight have to hit one pound an hour and
he was good about it actually wasn't
that hard of a wicket he did it really
well we're very disciplined I was with
him the last 48 hours making sure he was
doing everything the last few steps
really well the rehydration process I
was with him the whole time though did
he wake up at Friday morning
Friday morning I'll tell you right now
it weighs it's not great I mean okay so
so one o'clock in the morning he was 164
oh one o'clock in the morning nine
pounds ago five o'clock in the morning
he was 163 that's when we start so I let
him sleep for a couple hours four hours
four hours of sleep
wake up so you woke him up at 5:00 yeah
the day of the weigh-ins the day of the
weigh-in Wow wake up wake up wake up
trying to make weight at 10 o clock he
was 155 oh wow so he went through from 5
a.m.
all the way to 10 yes and what is he
doing during that time a bath bath bath
and then wrap him up in the towels let
him sweat in the towels Jesus Christ and
then no sauna
no no sauna for this one how come some
guys prefer baths it's direct heat what
do you like I like
I think I tell guys if you're not used
to the Sunnah let's do bath like I
always tell guys before your fight go
once a week to the sauna like six weeks
out because sauna takes practice some
people sit in the Sun of 45 minutes and
is nothing like they have sauna World
Championship so I don't know if you know
that but like in like Finland they have
the World Championships of sauna like
some people stay in there for hours like
you build a tolerance
[Applause]